[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal sur tv fil 78 2 voici
les principaux titres d'image de ce
lundi à 22 mai ils sont 174 174
candidates et candidats à briguer un
poste de député dans les yvelines 12
circonscriptions sont à pourvoir entre
renouveau et continuité le point complet
au cours de cette édition avec la
candidature de paris pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines pourrait
rayonner à travers le monde plusieurs
sites pourraient accueillir des épreuves
présentation tout au long de cette
semaine dans le journal
et aujourd'hui nous irons à elancourt au
sommet de la colline et puis retour sur
la nuit des musées ce week end le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
qui ouvrait à notamment à ses portes
et tout d'abord cette information le
président russe vladimir poutine se
rendra le 29 mai au château de
versailles pour y être reçu par le
président français emmanuel macron les
deux hommes vont visiter l'exposition
consacrée aux déplacements de pierre le
grand en france en 1717 une exposition
réalisée en partenariat avec le musée de
l'ermitage de saint-pétersbourg et qui
marque les 300 ans de relations
diplomatiques entre la france et la
russie
on en vient à l'actualité sociale le
premier opérateur français de transport
adapté des personnes en véhicule vortex
étaient en grève ce lundi matin à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats les
salariés ont manifesté sur différents
sites de la société dont l'un d'entre
eux se trouve à guyancourt ils demandent
une revalorisation de leurs contrats ils
soupçonnent également leurs responsables
de détourner les profits de la société
écouter alexandre fritz c'est le délégué
du personnel
accueilli en cours la direction n'a pour
l'instant pas répondu favorablement à
nos demandes d'interview
au jour d'aujourd'hui ils ont ils se
sont présentés au marché
c'est un marché public au moins dix ans
c'est à dire pour obtenir le marché
il propose des coûts les plus bas
possible et ça se répercute sur le
salaire des gens et sur leurs conditions
de travail
aujourd'hui ils disent qu'on leur coupe
de l'argent or au jour d'aujourd'hui
quand il répondu au marché il était déjà
en déficit
c'était pour couvrir des pertes qu'ils
avaient ailleurs qu'ils ont répondu au
marché ils ont
tenues ce marché ils disent qu'on leur
coupe de l'argent quand ils ont répondu
aux marchés savaient très bien combien
ça coûte et le personnel et combien le
coût de gestion
donc ils pouvaient ils peuvent pas dire
qu'ils sont ignorants là-dessus
politique
à présent elle législatives après les
bons résultats de jean luc mélenchon la
france insoumise espère décrocher des
postes à l'assemblée et pourquoi pas
peser significativement dans l'hémicycle
qu'attendre du scrutin dans c'est pour
cette formation dans les yvelines plus
spécifiquement c'est avec nicolas landry
et nicolas kirilow x12 insoumis seront
candidats dans les yvelines certains
sont issus de la société civile
sapeurs-pompiers artisans boulangers
photographes ou encore salarié d'une
multinationale
c'est le parcours de benjamin nicoletta
candidat dans la 10e circonscription
face à une gauche divisée en 5 et au
duel déjà anticipé entre jean frédéric
poisson et aurore bergé
il veut se démarquer sur la manière de
gouverner les conférences citoyennes
qu'on voudra mettre en place aussi la
france a soumis ce gagne dans l'ensemble
de la france c'est pour faire remonter
les idées si vous voulez du terrain j'ai
moi j'ai un égard par un regard
particulier la politique où je me dis
que les personnes qui ont réponse à tout
déjà c'est quelque chose qui me chagrine
ce que je veux c'est que ça vienne
vraiment du terrain autres
circonscriptions ancré à droite est
difficile à conquérir celles de david
douillet député sortant de la 12e sur la
ligne de départ la gauche par là aussi
désunis mais la france insoumise croit
en sa qualification au second tour
je pense que si vous étiez avec moi dans
certains quartiers notamment de plus
de poids si vous vous verriez qu'il ya
un engouement pour ce groupement de la
france assure eu quand même
extraordinaire première force de gauche
sur la 11e circonscription jean luc
mélenchon a totalisé près de 25% des
voix lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017
une victoire est donc possible pour la
france insoumise malgré la présence
d'autres candidatures à gauche dont
celle du parti communiste français
c'est la proposition qu'on a adressé à
liquidret et aux communistes de la
circonscription
donc voilà ils ont fait le choix eux
décliné cette proposition de maintenir
la candidature de luc miserait donc
voilà c'est une situation qui a été fort
regrettable dans les autres
circonscriptions on retrouve thibault
marshall dans la première enfin sur la
deuxième et la troisième circonscription
les candidats de la france insoumise
devons faire face à des candidatures
communes entre europe ecologie les verts
le parti socialiste et le pcf
et parmi ces candidats de la france
insoumise dans les yvelines marc soriano
cet auteur dramaturge est installé en
résidence au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines depuis 2008
l'année au cours de laquelle il a décidé
de s'engager aux côtés de jean luc
mélenchon sa campagne est à l'image de
son activité théâtrale avec une oeuvre
artistique le jardin planétaire une
construction utilisés pour défendre
l'environnement il se présente dans la
2e circonscription celle notamment de
vélizy je vais axer ma campagne sur ces
questions là sur qu'est ce qu'on mange
qu'est-ce qu'on respire enfin tout ce
qui tout ce qui met en jeu le vivant et
qui nous concerne tous par delà les les
chicaillas habituels et les insoumis ce
sont ceux qui veulent relever la tête
contre le dogme libéral c'est à dire
celui des chiffres des tableaux de bord
de la rentabilité de la déshumanisation
permanente au profit de la rentabilité
de la compétitivité être insoumis c'est
tout simplement demandé à ce que l'homme
redevienne le centre des préoccupations
politiques et non pas l'argent qui comme
vous le savez ne se mange pas et dans
cette course aux élections législatives
on connaît dorénavant les noms de tous
les candidats dans les différentes
circonscriptions yvelinoise tv fil 78
s'intéresse plus particulièrement au sud
d
yvelines nicolas bonsoir bonsoir
circonscription qui nous concerne
directement et un constat un nombre de
candidats et candidates plutôt important
oui au total sur ces six
circonscriptions il y à 87 candidats
c'est beaucoup plus qu'il y a 5 en 2012
il y avait 72 candidats au départ sur le
même bassin
c'est donc 15 de plus et la palme de la
circonscription entre guillemets la plus
convoitée revient à la deuxième celle de
vélizy et d'une partie de versailles
ils sont 17 au total à se battre pour la
députation
ces quatre de plus par exemple que sur
la 11e circonscription où il n'y a entre
guillemets que treize candidats mais en
moyenne vous le voyez wilfried on se
situe à chaque fois largement au dessus
de la barre des 10 candidats ce qui est
de compliquer le choix des électeurs à
noter enfin que seuls deux députés
sortants deux députés sortants ne se
représentent pas françois de mazières
sur la première circonscription et henri
guaino sur l'aa troisième à françois de
mazières qu'on a aperçu et qui préfère
se concentrer sur sa municipalité et
henri guaino qui lui en revanche n'a pas
reçu l'investiture des républicains pour
la 3e circonscription la parité en tout
cas n'est pas forcément respectée une
nouvelle fois oui une nouvelle fois
c'est une constance elles sont 30 et une
à se présenter sur les six
circonscriptions qui nous concerne ce
qui correspond à un peu plus de d'un
tiers de femmes candidates et tout en
bas du classement on retrouve la
première circonscription avec seulement
trois femmes pour onze hommes la parité
est respectée finalement que sur la 12e
circonscription avec cette femme et cet
homme et signe d'un vieux système qui
semble se perdurer tout de même
l'égalité est respectée en revanche et
les suppléants ou 43 femmes feront
campagne aux côtés de leur candidat et
il y aura une campagne plutôt musclée
sur certains territoires
en effet on peut retenir de deux
exemples qui vont sûrement animer ces
prochaines semaines à commencer par la
10e circonscription où le député sortant
jean-frédéric poisson au candidat de la
droite se reposer à aurore bergé
candidate en marche
transfuge des républicains les
hostilités ont déjà largement débuté sur
les réseaux sociaux et via les médias
entre les deux candidats et puis il
faudra suivre aussi le match retour
entre guillemets sur la 11e
circonscription entre le socialiste
benoît hamon
et le candidat de la droite jean michel
fourgous s'était déjà les deux candidats
finalistes en 2012 et au vu des
résultats de la présidentielle il faudra
aussi compter sur l'inconnu en marche
nadia et et le candidat de la france
insoumise mathurin lévis est donc une
possible bataille à 4 qui se dessine sur
cette circonscription où wilfrid merci
nicolas je rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver toute l'actualité de cette
campagne sur notre site internet est
également sur notre application mobile
et puis chaque jour 1 re quotidien au
cours des différentes éditions de nos
journaux d'information avant de quitter
la politique un coup d'oeil sur l'agenda
de la campagne à david douillet sera en
meeting du côté de neauphle le vieux
demain le député sortant patron des
républicains dans les yvelines entend
conserver son poste dans la 12e
circonscription dans la dixième à
présent frédéricton salaces et du
courant 577 pour la france se rend lui à
réseau dans le même temps toujours dans
la dixième son adversaire socialiste va
rencontrer les militants à désessard et
le député sortant lui dans la dixième
jean frédéric poisson président du parti
chrétien démocrate sera à gaz devant et
puis une dernière date celle de pascale
poirot dans la deuxième map voisins le
bretonneux
c'est un proche d'ailleurs de jean
frédéric poisson et du parti chrétien
est démocrate voilà pour la politique
pour ce soir cette semaine tv fil 78
vous proposez également de partir à la
rencontre et à la découverte des
différents sites yvelinois retenus dans
le cadre de la candidature paris 2024
pour les jeux olympiques aujourd'hui
coup de projecteur sur la colline
d'elancourt c'est le point culminant
d'ile-de-france et les épreuves de vtt
pourrait s'y déroulent et reportages
mais quel ennemi dans la colline
d'elancourt deviendra-t-elle enfin une
colline olympique le projet dans les
cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a été
ressortie pour la candidature de paris
aux jo de 2024
le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force c'est l'unité de lieu
le deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir quelque chose de
très raide
donc oui c'est assez naturel que ça
vienne ici sur la sur la colline de la
hanche
pour rendre ce site totalement
opérationnel pour les jeux olympiques
quelques travaux sont nécessaires dans
ce lieu à l'état presque sauvage des
tribunes seront construites en amont de
la colline les organisateurs vont
également devoir façonner un parcours
entre 4 et 6 km avec des sentiers des
secteurs goût tournée des partis en
sous-bois pour répondre au cahier des
charges
cet aménagement c'est pas pour
construire c'est vraiment pour modeler
donc on va on le fait avec avec des
rochers de la pierre avec du bord avec
avec également des troncs d'arbres on
est vraiment dans du modelage donc on
peut le faire avec des produits sur
place avait avec des gravats également
le vtt reste quand même une discipline
de pleine nature et on joue avec ce que
l'on a ce qu'on en a sous les pieds pour
construire ce parcours d'une durée d'une
heure trente les organisateurs pourrait
s'appuyer sur les clubs locaux et
notamment le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisateurs
de la revanchard d'une épreuve de vtt
qui fêtera cette année ses 19 ans on a
notre aider sur les aspects techniques
mais j'espère qu'on pourra solliciter
les acteurs locaux on a des clubs qui
sont mobilisés des clubs locaux qui a
dans la pratique du vtt sont sont
également très présents et ils
connaissent mieux les lieux que
n'importe qui ici donc certainement
qu'ils doivent bien les connaître et
donc c'est ce sera plus de s'appuyer sur
leur connaissance du terrain
le coût total de l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt pour les jo n'est
pas encore connue si le cio désignera
france en septembre prochain
les premiers coups de pioche pourrait
être donné d'ici 2020 culture 13e
édition de la nuit européenne des musées
plus de 2 millions de visiteurs en
france à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
le musée de la ville qui était ouvert un
espace de retrogaming géant puisque la
proposition de cette année s'inscrivait
dans le cadre de l'exposition temporaire
vintage regard dans le rétro nicolas
d'ambri est aller s'amuser sur place
le musée de la ville séparée en deux
univers parallèles de monde relié par un
thème le vintage super mario des
vaisseaux spatiaux et des voitures de
course peuplent cet espace retrogaming
joueurs initiés et débutants se côtoient
c'est un peu dur hein parce que moi j'ai
pas l'habitude de jouer ces noms jeu de
voiture j'aime bien laver la vitesse
mais là j'ai pas trop l'habitude donc
j'essaye mais bon c'est rigolo c'est
rigolo c'est mon fils qui joue
d'habitude ans et mon mari elle avait
pas de jeu vidéo quand tu étais petit
mail avait des bonnes notes à l'école
vous appuyez sur les touches jouées ce
que ça donne
à droite
nintendo sega et sony des consoles en
libre accès jusqu'au tournoi multi
joueurs sur le jeu bomberman une
chronologie bouleversée entre années
soixante dix et 90 pour faire découvrir
aux enfants les anciennes consoles notre
époque quoi donc voilà un peu de
nostalgie
l'idée c'est vraiment que ce soit
intergénérationnel c'est que ça touche
un public qui soit un public de jeunes
adultes mais c'est aussi de mélanger
vraiment les générations les plus jeunes
les trentenaires les quarantenaires qui
ont connu ces jeux et qui en jouait
enfant mais aussi les personnes plus
âgées qui n'ont pas forcément quand on
ne sait jamais qui les redécouvre autre
ambiance mais toujours rétro avec
l'exposition temporaire du musée veste
en cuir tourne-disque flipper les
visiteurs redécouvre des objets du
siècle dernier
cette treizième nuit européenne des
musées est rassemblé près de 400
personnes à la croisée des deux mondes
du musée de la ville merci d'avoir suivi
ce journal les programmes à retrouver
sur notre site internet prochaine
édition du journal demain aux horaires
habituels
[Musique]